it's just such rewarding work you know
when you think about what we do is
righteous work we develop drugs that
help to cure or alleviate human
suffering terrible human diseases and so
that in and of itself is a wonderful
calling it's a wonderful thing to do
with your life I think secondly and
probably on a more personal note back in
1996 my daughter was three and my son
was seven my wife found out that she had
breast cancer and so for four and a half
years we did surgery and chemotherapy
and radiation and just tried everything
and it's a terrible disease and
unfortunately that we weren't able to
stay weren't able to save her life and
she passed on and so you realize I think
the value and sanctity of what we do
because even though those medicines and
those chemotherapies and radiations
couldn't heal her then the technologies
we work on today may heal somebody in
the future and that is rewarding work
well you know it's a I think you learned
to value life and living for each day
you know we spend so much time worrying
you know that we forget the everyday
simple joys of being with our children
or spending time with our friends are
enjoying the beauty of God's creation in
nature now as sad as it was that my wife
passed away in two thousand I recognize
I was very fortunate to meet another
person here at pfizer and we got married
and we actually have a our third child
as is Kate and so as sad as that story
is this one kind of has a happy ending
because you realize that life goes on
and I realized whichever way I went
that's the way the kids were going to go
and so you use the support of your
family your church family in my case
your pfizer family which is kind of
awesome and through that you learn to
move on each day but i would say for me
specifically when you when you have a
situation like this in your life it
gives you tremendous perspective and so
people will come and say that Jesus we
got a problem and I say no that's not a
problem this is a problem that may be an
inconvenience maybe unfortunate but it's
very doable it's very workable it's not
a problem and so one thing I guess that
I'm blessed that it's given me I'm a
much better father now than I ever was a
much better husband now than I ever was
I think as a person you become a much
better person because you realize the
sanctity of life and so that's the
tremendous value of I think what Pfizer
does what the pharmaceutical industry
does is they deliver medicines that will
hopefully one day continue to leave e8
this human suffering
let's be honest it's kind of amazing
it's really kind of unbelievable when
you think of all the biochemistry that
happens in our body and all these
proteins and cofactors and things that
are circulating that we can't see and
that they all work in perfect harmony to
keep us healthy but when something gets
out of whack just like our external
environment through environmental
factors or for through pollution you
know the same things can happen to our
bodies and so there's this very fragile
balance so to be able to study science I
think and see how ph affects what we eat
and how we eat affects our metabolism
and how are what we eat maybe affects
our cholesterol let's say something
we're all worried about our waistline
how it can contribute to these different
diseases you suddenly become very aware
Jesus if I want to live longer maybe we
have to eat better and exercise more
you